I did a whole video recently about
buying versus renting in today's market
and I analyzed the average price based
on the average income of a person versus
the average rent rents are still
substantially cheaper over the lifetime
of the average ownership of 13 years
interes if you plan to live in the home
for less than about 11 and 1/2 years if
you're going to be in this house for the
next 10 years fantastic decision if
you're only going to be in here a few
years and then you know I might sell it
and then move somewhere else chances are
it would have been way cheaper to rent
toally
I regret the decision overall
financially with the house and where it
is and being close to friends I don't
regret it LifeWise but I definitely
regret it financially